to put it briefly this is a European
summit but before we get to the flesh
and bones of what the European Council
is you need to remember that the
European Council has nothing to do with
the Council of Europe it is based in
Strasbourg in France and is an
international organisation focusing
almost exclusively on human rights and
democracy so how long have European
summits been taking place a bit of
history the first one was in 1974 when
the former French president valéry
Giscard d'Estaing
wanted to create a club where the heads
of state and government could meet
regularly and ever since these summits
have been setting the pattern for the
--use political life but only in 2009
with the Treaty of Lisbon did the
European Council become a real
institution with a president appointed
for a term of two and a half years
renewable once so what are these great
political and media shows really for
surprising as it may seem the European
Council has no legislative power only
the European Commission can propose laws
on the other hand the European Council
defines at the highest level the wider
political directions and priorities of
the Union
however it's becoming harder and harder
to reach the famed European compromise
especially with 28 heads of state and
government at the table the general idea
today is to take decisions by consensus
since November 2014 for a decision to be
adopted it must obtain the support of 55
percent of the states representing at
least 65% of the union's population of
500 million people but some decisions
can also be taken by unanimity by
extension
that means each state has a right to
veto on some issues for example to put
on record a state serious and persistent
violation of EU values issues of foreign
policy or common security or to approve
amendments to the EU treaties
seizure has been simplified but let's
come back to European summits in reality
a major part of the negotiations takes
place well before the summit everything
happens in the wings between diplomats
foreign ministers and European civil
servants in fact it's even possible to
obtain a rough draft of the summit
conclusions before the heads of state
even arrive so how do journalists get
informed when the discussions are held
behind closed doors they don't they have
to wait until the conclusion of every EU
summit often for hours but in truth the
debates are never a totally secret
during a summit each delegation
organizes press briefings there are the
record but information still circulates
informally and for those who can't get
to summits social media has stepped in
if you type hashtag EU CEO on Twitter
you can follow the progress of
discussions almost live without being in
the building talking of buildings the
heads of state used to meet here in the
Eustis lip seus building but from now on
they will also meet in the europa
building in brussels
you